We now would like to explore
the concept of potential energy
difference for a
conservative force.
Let's consider the
following case.
Suppose you have
an object of mass m
and it's located at a
certain height y i initial.
And so this is
our initial state.
And we would like to
move this object upwards.
So it goes up to
a height y final.
This is our final state.
And in our initial
state, we might
have some initial velocity.
And then the final state
might have some final speed.
And what we'd like
to do now is--
we know that if there is
a gravitational force, mg,
acting downwards, that
this gravitational force is
a conservative force.
And now what I'd like to do
is-- because the force is
conservative, it doesn't
depend on the path
that our object goes
to the final state.
It just depends
on the parameters
that describe the initial
and the final states.
In fact, we'll see it only
depends on the initial height
and the final height.
So what I'd like to do is define
a potential energy difference
in the following way.
So as a definition, the
potential energy difference
between these two
points is given
by the negative of the work
done by the gravitational force
in going from the initial
state to the final state.
Notice this negative sign.
Because the gravitational
force here, Fg
is minus mg j hat-- where
we're taking j hat up--
we've seen that
this is an example
of a conservative force.
And it doesn't matter how
we went from the initial
to the final states.
So we can generalize this
idea for potential energy.
But first, let's just remind
ourselves of the calculation.
When we did this
calculation before,
we had u final minus u final
initial equals a negative sign
in the definition.
And when we calculated the work
done by the conservative force,
we had negative mg y
final minus y initial.
Notice the two minus signs.
So we get mg y final
minus y initial.
Now, many times people
talk about changes
in potential energy.
So when I write delta u, I mean
precisely the potential energy
at the final state
minus potential energy
of the initial state-- the
change in potential energy.
And that's equal to mg times
the change in the displacement.
And so we see here
for this example,
that if delta y
is positive, that
implies that the potential
energy is increasing.
Now let's connect that
to our definition.
Why is the potential
energy increasing
when we raise something?
Well, the gravitational
force points downwards.
The displacement is upwards.
So the work done is negative.
And another minus sign means
the change in potential energy
is positive.
If the object is moving
with no change in height,
that tells us that the potential
energy is change is zero.
And finally, if delta
y is less than zero,
that implies that the change in
potential energy is negative.
Now again let's
examine this case.
If we were actually lowering
an object, dropping it down.
The object moved downward
from the initial state
to a final state, the
gravitational force
is downward, the
displacement is downward,
the integral is positive,
the extra minus sign
corresponds to the change
of potential energy
being negative.